so there was a rumor a long time ago
that the original title for Hogwarts
Legacy was intended to be Hogwarts Dark
Legacy now obviously that did not turn
out to be true and if you go back and
look at this original leak there is a
lot there that has since been proven
false it did not come to pass however
one thing that we have seen throughout
is that Hogwarts Legacy will not shy
away from the more darker aspects of The
Wizarding World and with Halloween
coming up I thought this would be a
great time take a look back on
everything we've seen so far and ask
ourselves the question just how dark is
this game going to go now there's been
some talk lately about the game's rating
and I fully expect that it will be a T
for teen here in the United States I
have thought that throughout the whole
entire time that Hogwarts Legacy has
been in development I would be very very
shocked if it got an M for Mature rating
I just do not expect that I think it's
going to be a solid tea for team in the
latest leak well honestly I don't even
think you can call it a leak because
because it was a PlayStation post on
Facebook that had the T14 rating now if
you go to the ESRB site at the time of
this recording it is not there but even
so given everything that we have seen
about Hogwarts Legacy so far I think it
is pretty clear that they are not going
to be shying away from the dark arts so
let's take a look at a few things here
that show this to be the case I mean
first of all take the very first state
of Play trailer when they did the full
gameplay reveal and they showed us there
none other than Avada Kedavra the most
prominent the most famous unforgivable
curse of all three the killing curse it
is in the game it's something that fans
have been asking for for quite some time
and now with that trailer we got
confirmation that it's going to be in I
mean so that alone tells you there's
going to be some serious dark magic
going on in Hogwarts Legacy and really
that was just the tip of the iceberg
then we got the trailer with Sebastian's
Dark Legacy and that is where they
confirmed the second unforgivable curse
crucio is going to be in the game so I
think at this point we could probably go
ahead and assume that yes Imperial is
definitely going to be in the game even
if they haven't confirmed it just yet
and also I've gone on records saying
that I think edada Kedavra is going to
only be possible as a finisher curse I
don't think it's going to be something
that you could just run around spamming
like crazy in the halls of Hogwarts I
just do not expect that I think it's
going to be something that is available
as a finisher only crucio is a bit of a
different story this could only be
available in certain story segments or
maybe it's going to be available to
subdue enemies I don't see it being a
finisher even though it can actually
make people go insane and in some ways
it can be even worse than a vodka davra
so we have those two curses officially
confirmed and then we got another
trailer with the PlayStation exclusive
Mission at least for one year that is
and that of course is the haunted
hogsmeade shop and this showed maybe the
darkest look that we have seen so far at
Hogwarts Legacy and something that just
looks straight up like a haunted house I
mean for lack of a better explanation
that is what it looks like here A
Haunted House that appears to be
inhabited by AI what many are guessing
is going to be a poltergeist and I think
this one was darker even than
Sebastian's trailer Sinister voices
throughout and these weird mannequins
that we thought I mean we saw them in
the Autodesk trailer and we thought they
were just gonna be something that was
there to kind of help the design team
but no they're actually in the game you
guys it's crazy and this is really
shaping up to just be a nightmarish sort
of quest here now one thing I love about
what we've seen so far is that they are
really setting this up to where it's not
just black and white dark arts are bad
everything else is good we still have a
lot more to learn about Sebastian here
but thanks to a couple of reveals that
they've done on their social media we
know yes Sebastian is going to tempt us
down the path of the dark arts he is
going to offer to teach us crucio
however he is doing all of this to try
and save his sister who is suffering
from a debilitating curse we even hear
Sebastian in the trailer say
spell that could save your life
shouldn't be unforgivable and it's
really an interesting point that he
brings up there I mean we even see Harry
Potter use the dark arts we see Harry
Potter use the unforgivable curses
probably the most notable example being
imperio in Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows when they use it straight up
fully knowing what they are doing to
take advantage of the Goblins to get
into Gringotts and dare I say they
decide that it's for the greater good in
this instance I am fully expected that
we are going to get an ASMR video maybe
even on Halloween that is going to be
very focused on the dark arts it would
not surprise me at all if this is a very
eerie creepy ASMR that we get here for
the fall and now I can't confirm this
myself but I have seen reports from
several fans that they actually tweeted
out a fall ASMR and then quickly deleted
the Tweet so again I can't confirm or
deny that but I do think it's almost a
100 lock that we are going to get a fall
ASMR and then subsequently a winter ASMR
that will no doubt showcase more
beautiful landscapes in and around
Hogwarts and what's crazy is we haven't
even talked about the dark magical
creatures yet in theory officially
confirmed to be in the game and I've
talked about this so many times at this
point but I'm gonna bring it up again an
important thing to remember about in
theory guys is that they are not natural
they only happen the only way an infuri
can exist is under the curse of a dark
Wizard and so that begs the question who
is the dark wizard behind the inferior
that we have seen throughout the
Hogwarts Legacy trailers and then
another big question when it comes to
dark creatures the Dementors we have
seen them we saw them in the first
trailer didn't see any of them in the
second trailer or any of the other
trailers that we have gotten so far
however they are on the official box art
for the dark arts version well I guess
that's not really the dark arts version
It's the deluxe edition of Hogwarts
Legacy we see Dementors there present on
that cover so how are the mentors going
to factor into this game now I'll give
you my prediction here I believe that we
at some point will be going to ask van
again I have no inside information on
this this is purely another guess
another theory and hey we've done pretty
well so far with our theories but I
believe that our power as a character
this power to detect ancient magic will
at some point take us to Azkaban and
that is where we will meet the Dementors
and if Dementors are in the game that
just begs the question expecto Patron I
mean it has to be in the game right it's
the only known way to fight against
Dementors and honestly I can't wait to
see how it all shakes out now in terms
of characters I know we talked a little
bit about Sebastian and His Dark Arts
but what other characters could possibly
turn to the dark side or at least use
dark magic in Hogwarts Legacy I already
have a full video breaking that down and
you can check it out on the right side
of your screen now as always thank you
all so much for watching I'll talk to
you again soon